but do you when you wake up in the
mornings do you feel white I do feel
like you're asleep okay you're asleep it
feels like I wake up and I'm like okay
I'm still six feet I got I have a
medium-sized penis yeah and I'm gonna go
a cup get out of bed I'm gonna be
sarcastic all day yes smart ass yeah I'm
gonna be but I'm gonna be happy-go-lucky
yeah very charming I'm gonna make people
I interact with laughs the witty quip
rise Wow wonder wonderful life what do
you wake up feeling like sweet I feel
weight like a where your shoulders no oh
my stomach okay there's a weight on my
stomach I'm like oh my god I'm fat yeah
and then I when I stand up a little more
it doesn't take that long because my
legs are so short I just kind of lift up
and I'm up on my feet there's no
movement I just kind of roll on my feet
yeah oh my god what happened and then
kind of go to the bathroom and I go to
the bathroom I TP and I then let you
look at your penis and go I sent you
dick pics but I zoomed in on them
groundworks go hey man I think Bobby
likes me right I'm like why he shows me
his phone it's like 20 dick no not even
attacks just dick pic after dick fit no
explanation Oakland A's you know because
we were shooting because the scene that
we shot Kris and I we were on it was a
party scene where Paul rust character we
can't give it a bit away there was a
party scene and so there's 20
reoccurring people on there I'm you got
Jason dill Andy Dick you got Rachel
sands you marry Kenny yeah that you have
60 so we're sitting around where we're
sitting in this party and there's
nothing else to do so I just kept
selling Chris dick pics okay so is
sexual harassment in the workplace oh I
don't know
I could probably have you oh yeah if
Chris went to a producer yeah and set
and was really bombed and said god this
[ __ ] asian guy you know Bobby
he keeps selling me pictures of his
penis that's it yeah I'm it's a good
thing you enjoy him nuts on it you guys
think I'm [ __ ] but I I'm not gonna
sense that I have that kind of
relationship with this guy yeah
he gave me his number and then as soon
as he gave me as I'm like is he ready
for a dick pic in my head I'm like eight
years and I was and you know that we hit
it off right away right away you can
tell yeah you didn't tell because we
just immediately started [ __ ] with
each other like Gillian Jacobs we all my
scenes are pretty much with her and I
love her no I would never in my whole
life I don't think that most people
would like it actually like Judd Apatow
if I see another dick pic I don't think
it would like he's too many you know he
tweeted a picture of me one time did he
uh-huh and it was great I'm for real he
tweeted like love season 2 we're working
on it and it was a picture of me and the
two old guys all right made my day my
week how does that make you feel sweetie
really bad I would kill for your career
that lunch thing with him he went with a
luncheon with him with Jerry Seinfeld
yeah what oh yeah you invited me to a
luncheon but not through text through
his I don't know if there was a system
how long ago was this why was Seinfeld
yeah Seinfeld had a benefit thing right
so I was at Judge table so it was me
Judd Wayne Federman
I forgot how long and then this him
unless it was Sebastian and all those
guys and then just you know Seinfeld
came to the table hello and his wife
called him Robbie
[Laughter]
although that was funny but did they
hire you as like a seat filler or like
was it oh oh you're a benchwarmer baby
that was a very funny joke
and I'm absorbing the joke very good
very good
thank
[Music]